you were an american gangster great film
uh you said it's one of your favorites
too what um
you were in it with denzel washington
what makes that movie meaningful to you
what uh what was it like making that
movie because the great great america
was that was a great american film there
was so many things in that film being a
part of that film was probably
a blessing and a treasure
uh because if i even if i wasn't a part
of it uh
it this course such great filmmaking and
and to me a really cool great story
um
the thing that i
love about it the most
really is
the process of it
you know which part of the process i
wouldn't have known the process if i
wasn't part of it
so as a film joyous it was great feeling
but even the process of making it was
like
a high level education for me on
multiple levels i'm working with ridley
scott
which is and this is a bold statement if
i say this here because i got a lot of
friends that's going to probably
but he's probably the best living
director
because
watching him
allow me to understand a principle that
i've coined to him and i don't know if
people use it yet
called multivision
he seems to have the capacity
to see
eight
things at one time i heard on robin hood
he had 18 cameras i wasn't there for
that
and i think he keeps him all in his mind
just see i seen him do it
when he went to the monitors with the
video playback guy yeah i seen him bring
everything back to to a point
but nothing was the same on the frame
he was already there yeah and he knew if
he had what he was or not
and he placed the cameras there
and he and he he saw it like in his own
way
and i peeped it
you know i peep this yeah and i said yo
and i just you know humbly asked him he
was like
he was gracious enough to speak to me
and talk to me
uh and and confirm
of what i thought i saw he confirmed it
he confirmed it and i was able to
utilize it as i'm a filmmaker now
and i'm i see i can at least see three
or four things i can't see eight yet i'm
i'll be there though
um but i could definitely
like even right now
just if i could go like this in the room
okay
i got it now i got like
how to make this right here which is
just us all sitting how do i make this
dramatic look boom
come on there's a story there it's a
story there and i might just go off his
hanging watch or his hanging wristband
yeah you know because there's something
else there too is he dead we don't know
exactly
so so
he has this
and even though this is the scene yeah
you keeping that in mind all of this in
mind yeah
what about like
can you give an inkling of other parts
of the process like the editing like
where does the mouse happen another
thing pedro i don't pronounce pedro last
name right he's a he's a cool guy i had
a chance to play rugby with him he was
on was he on my team yeah well we went
both teams
but pedro
the editor who
you know added many
great films once again
he
has
i will call the ciphering power
but a good editor is a decipher almost
like breaking the enigma
because
he's dealing with
thousands
or we'll call it a film with millions of
feet of film at least a million feet of
film that's a lot of film before feature
he's dealing with that
but he's dealing with multiple cameras
yeah
so there's like it's like two cameras he
got an a b and he could just go back no
he may have six cameras and he has to go
back and
deal with that process and you know what
he knows how to tell the story
again
and he proved it
on american gangster as me being a
witness
because it's so much information
it's even when they when the brothers
all started getting their little
business and he put one in the bronx
and he just captured every neighborhood
within one minute
and you knew what happened you knew you
knew it all you knew you saw the whole
rise of fame so you watch the palmer and
scarface
uh who does it in two minutes
uh but it's only one character
so you see him go to the bank he drops
the money off you see him by the lion
you see him against his wife or the
tiger you see him against his wife you
see all that and then it ends on the big
side of him in the big house with all
the tv screens
and you've seen them go through it right
but an american gangster you're going to
tell that story of rising but you also
got to include these five brothers yeah
and so that's all in the edit oh man but
also all in the director knowing that as
well
and you got to keep track you got to
keep thinking about them because that
was a story right there yeah well i was
hearing it i don't know if they was
taking pictures of him or
yeah everybody's having a little party
over here yeah
jess i think
yeah i like it
they're playing chess
in the distance
this is great
you